[Música]
y volvemos con un tema económico
precisamente en esta sección de economía
directo américa ya está conmigo de
estudio daniel o landon dani bienvenida
feliz jueves feliz mañana vamos a hablar
de eeuu porque hay más vacantes que ese
empleo hola raúl un feliz día hasta el
penúltimo día de nuestra genuina final
sí pues mire según el departamento de
trabajo de eeuu hay 11 millones de
vacantes en este país ya quisiera algún
país de américa latina tenemos casi
iguala en el recordó que se había
analizado o que se había alcanzado mejor
en julio de este año en el décimo mes de
2021 también hubo 42 millones de
personas que renunciaron a sus trabajos
en eeuu este es el tercer registro más
alto desde que comenzaron a
contabilizarse los datos en el 2000 y en
total hay 74 millones de desempleados
que son apenas dos terceras partes del
total de las vacantes como vemos en este
gráfico como se explican y entonces este
fenómeno tiene algo que ver se aprende
médico y 19 claro raúl pérez mire en dos
décadas que se ha estado monitoreando el
tema lo normal era que hubiera más
desempleados que vacantes disponibles
pero eso cambió con la pandemia ésta si
fueras muestran dos cosas lo primero es
que las empresas tienen todo el ánimo de
expandirse ahora que están reactivando y
lo segundo que hay muchas compañías
persiguiendo a pocos empleados y esto
hace que quienes buscan empleo tengan
mayor poder de negociación y consigan
mejores salarios los conocedores del
tema raúl dicen que las razones que
llevan a la gente a no querer emplearse
tienen que ver con que muchos prefieren
vivir de las ayudas estatales otros no
quieren volver por miedo a contagiarse
del virus y algunos no tienen con quién
dejar a sus hijos bueno vamos a ver
hablar del gobierno chileno porque
propuse un aumento de la mesada
pensional pues así lo plasmó el
presidente sebastián piñera en un
proyecto de ley que propone que quienes
reciban una pensión básica de 176 mil
pesos chilenos o menos es decir 210
dólares pasen a devengar 185 mil pesos o
lo equivalente a 220 dólares y así
superaría la línea de pobreza por
primera vez el monto también aplicaría
para la pensión de invalidez y el
excedente será financiado por el estado
esto que quiere decir que no va a pasar
por las criticadas administradores de
fondos de pensiones sino que será como
un subsidio de todas maneras el gobierno
cree que unos 2,3 millones de personas
van a verse beneficiadas danny y en
belén auguran una triste navidad porque
pues miren la cuna del cristianismo se
están preparando para otra navidad sin
peregrinos raúl a comienzos de noviembre
el estado de israel que es el que ocupa
y tiene el control sobre los accesos a
cisjordania no se queda belén reabrió
sus fronteras a extranjeros con visa de
turista tras una larga clausura desde
marzo de 2020 en ese momento la
población de belén pensó que habían
superado lo peor y que poco a poco
volverían a la normalidad turística pero
ese optimismo les duró muy poco a
finales de ese mismo mes de noviembre
israel volvió a cerrar fronteras por la
variante o micro donde el coronavirus y
velense volvió a quedar sin turistas
escuchemos al alcalde
para la temporada navideña hicimos todo
lo que pudimos para promover a belen y
creo que fue una campaña media exitosa
pero lo que pasó con la nueva variante
del coronavirus y el cierre de las
fronteras de israel nos afectó esperamos
que esta pandemia no continúe que la
vida vuelva a su normalidad para que el
turismo vuelva a la ciudad y comencemos
a dinamizar de nuevo nuestra situación
económica
raúl usted conoce a belen no me
encantaría conocerlo a mí también y le
cuento que 8 de cada 10 personas en este
sitio viven del turismo pues por
supuesto a nivel en web
lamentable navidad para las que los que
vienen velen ahora vamos con los
indicadores pues de la agencia
calificadora de riesgo fitch degradó al
gigante chino ever brand a la categoría
de default debido a la falta de pago de
sus obligaciones sin embargo el mercado
asiático ya lo daba por descontado y sus
bolsas en lugar de bajar pues subieron
las bolsas europeas operan en
ligeramente en rojo en la jornada del
jueves pendiente del dato de inflación
en eeuu que está por conocerse y cifra
el día usted ha probado las sopas estas
enlatadas de campo sí y no me gustan
para nada
me gusta pero la mayoría de gente le
gusta sobre todo en eeuu y mire las
cifras son los 2.240 millones que fueron
de dólares por supuesto que fueron las
ventas trimestrales de esta compañía
cambio el psuv hasta octubre y bajaron
4.4 por ciento la compañía reconoce que
la gente ya dejó de comer en su hogar
para volver a los restaurantes y
advierte que seguirá subiendo sus
precios por culpa de los mayores gastos
en mano de obra y en materias primas
como también lo están haciendo sus
padres por ejemplo craft james que es la
de salsa de tomate que es así es imagino
que le
dan y gracias por toda la información
económica nos vemos más adelante con
economía ahora vamos a pasar a ver
nuestro reportaje del día